our series earth 365 looks at issues
affecting the health of our planet 365
days a year and later today on this day
President Biden will travel to Egypt for
the U.N climate conference big question
there is who should pay for the
devastation already caused by climate
change that issue high on the agenda
poor countries who did not contribute
the most to climate change want
financial help from wealthier Nations
who did senior National and
environmental correspondent Ben Tracy
spoke to one world leader whose country
has been hit hard
we cannot wait for speeches when the sea
is rising around us all the time it was
a brilliant bit of stagecraft the
foreign minister of the Pacific island
nation of tuvalu Knee Deep in water
warning world leaders that his country
is running out of time
[Music]
are demanding that richer Nations pay
for the irreversible harm their
pollution has already caused the U.N
calls this loss in damage essentially
climate reparations we are going to
suffer our people are going to suffer
Sheikh Hasina is prime minister of
Bangladesh
a country battered by climate extremes
including devastating Cyclones and
rising sea levels predicted to swamp its
coasts
you're talking about millions of people
having to move away from the coast
that's true already people are suffering
they should think about it it is not to
just make promise
it's time to take action
by they she means countries that got
rich by burning fossil fuels and are
responsible for most of the carbon
dioxide pollution overheating the planet
the United States the European Union in
more recently China are the world's top
three historic emitters it is the duty
what I feel this is their Duty yeah it
is their duty to assist because they are
responsible for it who don't do any
emission but we are sufferers
Bangladesh emits less than one percent
of the world's CO2
as does Pakistan still reeling from
historic flooding that has killed more
than 1500 people in recent months loss
and damage can no longer be swept under
the rug
it is a moral imperative the U.N
Secretary General says the world's
wealthiest Nations need to do more some
European countries stepped up this week
in Egypt but most others including the
U.S have resisted direct payments
fearing they could be seen as an
admission of liability the word
compensation is all kind of loaded
implications U.S climate Envoy John
Kerry recently defended U.S opposition
while saying he's open to discussions so
how this works is is trickier than meets
the eye
but developed Nations have already
failed to make good on a promise made it
a 2009 U.N climate Summit to provide 100
billion dollars a year by 2020.
to help vulnerable countries adapt to
Future climate impacts why why then
neglecting us prime minister Hasina says
wealthy countries can't just focus on
the energy of the future
without paying for the sins of the past
they have to take the responsibility all
these vulnerable people those who are
suffering because of the global warming
let them recover their losses and live
in a better life for CBS mornings I'm
Ben Tracy in Washington